osvaldo writing in how do I communicate
and Mark it to a customer who already
feels satisfied well as the holiday the
good news is they know why your ideas a
great idea the half of the job is done
the next half of the job because
actually it's much harder to sell to a
customers don't know why they want your
price especially the first bell so
typically and I've done that i did a
start-up and the first two years we were
out there pitching the idea and when i
look back and reflect on that first
couple years we were actually educating
the market we were educated and market
to assume that they had a need at the
time and actually I'd you know just kind
of like okay extreme examples that
you've been opened Steve Jobs SAT there
with the Apple board holding up I've
over 1 years again was there anybody in
the world that we need integrated camera
work around the phone computer no no
yeah everybody thought at the time is
pretty crazy in the ad kind of
blackberry and Nokia national as
dominant players and markedly so it's
harder actually to educate a market now
the good news is if your customers
satisfied then they didn't know they had
a need and and that needs kind of
quarter to a third level so it means you
can kind of go in there and say wow if
you did it with my product it just takes
you to the next level you kind of
obviously get it you're smart but I you
you've bought a price that kind of does
it but one my products so much better
and then you can be very explicit about
what the benefits are because that
customer and typically you actually kind
of some rules or benefit we haven't
talked about this before it but I'm
surprised actually some rules of benefit
either it saves them money either it
grows their top line quicker either it
makes their life EP or it sort of
appeals to you could say their ego or it
makes them feel better or you know all
those sort of things so they're kind of
the full
Reddington almost anything you could do
with a product as shares the kind of
indiscipline if it's a product or even
the service you see what is the need and
that sounds like an escape is pretty
well established customer so much and
then you look at your product relative
to why they're satisfied and say why did
can I give them additional benefits that
will really appeal to them by program
grow their business faster or helping
whether business part-time until better
for themselves I can take cost out of
their business although so I can make a
more efficient so there's a kind of spam
this kind of playbook of benefits that
you can play in that the good news is
they already get it they've woken up the
drank the kool-aid and now you can take
them to the next level and sell on the
benefits and pitch the benefits
explicitly the product and hopefully
that will mean they're well educated and
they totally get it and actually could
be kind of a rat very rapid sort of self
referral to close them out what I would
add to it is i would also really put
some guy into the relationship you know
you might be in a market where there is
no differentiation where if you're
selling you know financial products
everybody's selling the same thing if
you're real estate agent you're selling
the same thing yes those differences i
guess in your ability to sell maybe but
really you're telling the same thing and
so the difference is the relationship
and so if there with a current supplier
and you want to supplant them then i
would just try to really also build
unpoppable everything Steven said which
is amazing I would also look at that
book the relationship how do I out
service these guys compared to what
they're currently getting and form a
tight communication with them so they
understand that I care about them and
they feel like I'm going to care more
about them than where we're currently
with that could be reason enough to want
to switch over and give me the next
contract and deal so servicing the
relationship saw on top of all of the
you know clear easy-to-understand
benefits i think would really help you
win those deals